نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن تحليلات اجرتها
وكالات الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان مصداقيه
حماس ونفوذها تناميا بشكل كبير خلال
الشهرين الماضيين منذ هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول وبدء العمليات
الاسرائيليه ونقلت سي ان ان عن مسؤولين
مطلعين قولهم ان حركه حماس نجحت في وضع
نفسها في بعض اجزاء العالم العربي
والاسلامي كمدافع عن ضيه الفلسطينيه
ومقاتله فعاله ضد اسرائيل كما نقلت عن
مسؤول كبير في الاداره الامريكيه قوله ان
حماس لم تكن منظمه ذات شعبيه كبيره قبل
السابع من اكتوبر واليوم اصبحت اكثر شعبيه
ونقلت عن مسؤولين امريكيين قولهم انهم
يراقبون العديد من المؤشرات الرئيسيه التي
تشير الى ان الدعم لحماس تزايد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واماكن اخرى في في
المنطقه ينضم الينا من واشنطن الكاتب
الصحفي سعيد عريقات سيد سعيد ما هي
المؤشرات التي ترصدها وكالات الاستخبارات
الامريكيه في حديثها عن تنامي نفوذ حماس
وعن تنامي الدعم لها
ايضا تحيه لك ولل المشاهدين المؤشرات التي
تستخدمها هي حقيقه مؤشرات تعتمد على
البيانات الميدانيه هناك الكثير من
الاستطلاعات التي تمارسها وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه عبر اي ربما
اي اجهزه اخرى او مؤسسات اخرى يعني نحن
ندرك تماما ان ان بي ار على سبيل المثال
وهو الراديو الوطني الامريكي المدعوم من
الحكومه الامريكيه ولكنه مستقل اجرى
استطلاعا مؤخرا وجد ان شعبيه حماس ارتفعت
من من 12% كما ذكرتي قبل السابع من اكتوبر
الى حوالي
44% اليوم ونرى هذا الارتفاع يحدث بشكل
مضطرد وليس غرابه في ذلك لانه حقيقه الشعب
الفلسطيني بالدرجه الاولى والشعب العربي
بدرجه ثانيه يؤيدون مقاومه هذا الاحتلال
الشرس
العنجهية سيد سعيد ولكن ماذا يعني ذلك
بالاداره بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه وهي
تناصب حماس
العداء نعم الاداره الامريكيه
صنفت حماس كحركه ارهابيه وعلينا ان نتذكر
ان الاداره الامريكيه صنفت منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه كحركه ارهابيه ولكن راينا ان
الرئيس الراحل ياسر عرفات حضر الى البيت
الابيض ربما اكثر من اي زعيم اخر حوالي
ثمان مرات بفتره وجيزه جدا فاذا الولايات
المتحده تعمل اي تصنف هذه التصنيفات او
تعي هذه التصنيفات لخدمه اهدافها السياسيه
وعندما ترى ان هذه السياسه هي سياسه فاشله
تغير ذلك رايناها تفعل ذلك مع الحوثيين
وانها تفعل ذلك مع القوى الكثيره ما اود
ان اقوله انه في نهايه المطاف لا يمكن
للاداره الامريكيه او لاي شخص جاد او قوه
جاده تريد ان تعمل من اجل ان يكون هناك
نوعا من الاتفاق او سلام في المنطقه وان
وان تحتوي هذا هذه الحرب من عدم الانتماء
لابد ان يكون هناك محاولات للتواصل معها
خاصه وان هذه الحركه اثبتت قدره عسكريه
قويه جدا ميدانيه قويه جدا جدا ولكن ايضا
قوه تفاوضيه مهمه جدا ولها اثر كبير
وبالتالي ستواجه الولايات المتحده في وقت
قريب اعتقد
ضروره ان يكون هناك لها حوار اذا كانت ان
تكون ذات وزن في المنطقه ان يكون لها حوار
مع كاف قوى القوى الفلسطينيه فهي تدرك
تماما ان حركه حماس رغم كل تصريحاتها وكل
العبارات التي تستخدمها لوصفها كحركه
شريره تدرك تماما ان هذه الحركه هي جزء
اساسي من النسيج الوطني الفلسطيني وانه لا
يمكن ان يكون هناك حلا او سلاما في
المنطقه دون ان يحقق الشعب الفلسطيني
اهدافه الوطنيه شكرا لك سيد سعيد عريقات
الكاتب الصحفي كنت معنا من
واشنطن حول نفس الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام
الله الكاتب والباحث السياسي ساري عرابي
سيد ساري هل فجام ما نقلته شبكه سي ان ان
عن تحليلات اجرتها وكالات الاستخبارات
الامريكيه عن تصاعد نفوذ حركه حماس بعد
السابع من
اكتوبر بالعكس هذه الاستنتاجات غير مفاجئه
بالنسبه لنا بل المفاجئ ربما ان تتاخر
وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه في
استنتاج معطيات من هذا النوع لا شك ان
القضيه الفلسطينيه تمثل اهم رافعه تعبو
ومعنويه للجماهير العربيه والاسلاميه فضلا
عن العداله الواضحه شديده الوضوح بالنسبه
للقضيه الفلسطينيه فالذي يتبنى هذه القضيه
الفلسطينيه بصوره جديه ويتمتع بمصداقيه
حقيقيه في مواجهه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
فضلا طبعا عن الاداء الفذ لان القضيه ليست
فقط قضيه خطابيه او قضيه مواجهه فحسب هناك
اداء ف اذهلت به حركه حماس الجماهير
العربيه والاسلاميه واثبتت الجماهير
العربيه الاسلاميه ان هذه الامه يمكنها
الحقيقه ان تفعل شيئا اذا توفرت لديها نفس
المصداقيه توفرت لديها نفس الجديه توفر
لديها نفس القدره على استثمار الموارد
فالمسالة مثلت حركه حماس للجماهير العربيه
والاسلاميه ايضا املا لهذه الجماهير كما
انني اعتقد ان نفوذ حركه حماس وارتفاع
شعبيتها نعم تفضلي سيد ساري كيف ستتعافى
بعض الانظمه مع هذا الواقع الجديد وهي لا
يعني تؤيد حركه حماس ولا
تدعمها يعني الحقيقه من ناحيه تحليل سياسي
موضوعي صرف سلوك النظام الاقليمي العربي
تجاه حركه حماس خصوصا بعد 27 اكتوبر هو في
الحقيقه سلوك محير من الناح حيه الموضوعيه
لان حركه حماس وفرت للنظام الاقليمي
العربي فرصه كبيره في الحقيقه لتحسين
مواقعه وتحسين نفوذه سواء في النظام
الاقليمي عموما او سواء في العلاقه مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كان بالامكان
تبني القضيه الفلسطينيه بصوره مختلفه كان
بالامكان الانفتاح على حركه حماس بصوره
مختلفه وكان بالامكان للنظام الاقليم
العربي ان يكسب ايضا الجماهير العربيه
بسلوك مختلف تجاه الحرب على غزه والعدوان
على غزه وتجاه الكارثه الانسانيه الموجوده
داخل قطاع غزه لكن للاسف الشديد النظام
الاقليمي العربي لم يستثمر ذلك بل تصرف
على الضد من ذلك تماما الامر الذي يمثل
صدمه في الحقيقه للجماهير العربيه ويسقط
هيبه النظام الرسمي العربي بالنسبه
للجماهير التي يحكمها هذا النظام لا سما
اذا نظرنا الى حاله العجز حاله التردي
حاله انعدام الكفاءه او ما يبدو لدى
العديدين ليس فقط تخاذلا وانما يبدو لدى
العديدين تواطؤا وبالتالي اذا اخذنا الامر
بصوره متقابله ما بين ارتفاع نفوذ الحركه
التي تواجه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وفي
المقابل هناك حاله واط بالتاكيد ثمت شك
كبير تجاه مصداقيه النظام الرسمي العربي
لدى الجماهير العربيه طيب على المستوى
الدولي ما اثر هذه النتائج على النظره
لحركه
حماس يعني اولا ليس امام النظام الدولي
عموما حتى بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا شك ان مشكله الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مع حماس مشكله مركبه من
جهه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تتعامل مع
اسرائيل بوصفها وكيلا امبراطور للمصالح
الامريكيه في هذه المنطقه ومن جهه ثانيه
لا تقبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
يكون هناك طرف حقيقي في هذا العالم ولا
سما ان كان طرفا عربيا مسلما او كان حركه
صغيره من حيث القدرات والامكانات تواجه
الهيبه الامريكيه والهيمنه الامريكيه في
هذا العالم لكن ليس امام هذا العالم في
الحقيقه امام الانجاز الاستراتيجي وامام
الانجاز السياسي الذي تحقق بهذه الاحداث
من حيث استعاده القضيه الفلسطينيه
لمكانتها على الاجنده الدوليه واثبات انه
لا يمكن طمس القضيه الفلسطينيه ولا يمكن
ان يوجد هناك ترتيبات في هذه المنطقه او
سلام في هذا العالم دون حل القضيه
الفلسطينيه انا اعتقد ان هذه الاستنتاجات
موجوده لدى الخبراء في الاجهزه في الدول
المتعدده بما في ذلك الدول الاوروبيه هناك
العديد من التقارير التي تتحدث ان الخبراء
الذين يعرفون المنطقه جيدا يعرفون السياسه
جيدا بعيدا عن المصالح الضيقه للادارات
الحاكمه في اوروبا او في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يرسلون العديد من التقارير سواء
على مستوى الاجهزه او على مستوى السفرات
او على مستوى وزارات الخارجيه هذه معركه
في الحقيقه سوف تنجز اهدافها بالتراكم
وانا اعتقد ان جانب اساسيا من ذلك قد انجز
وهو ما تحدث عنه اصلا وزير الدفاع
الامريكي حينما قال اذا كانت اسرائيل
قادره على ان تحقق انجازات عسكريه تكتيكيه
ولكن هذا السلوك سوف يؤدي الى هزيمه
استراتيجيه انا اعتقد ان القضيه
الفلسطينيه تستعيد مكانتها استراتيجيا
القضيه ليست حماس على وجه التحديد ولكن
حماس في هذه المعركه مثلت الرافعه التي
استعادت بها القضيه الفلسطينيه مكانتها
على المستوى الدولي شكرا لك سري عرابي
الكاتب والباحث السياسي كنت معنا من رام
الله حول نفس الموضوع ينضم الينا من غزه
الدكتور حسام الدجني الكاتب وال محلل
السياسي دكتور حسام هذه النتائج وما نقلته
سي ان ان عن وكالات استخبارات امريكيه اي
اثر له على العدوان الاسرائيلي المستمر
على قطاع
غزه يعني هو ترجمه حقيقيه لاكثر من اتجاه
الترجمه الاولى بفشل اهداف اسرائيل
بالقضاء على حمس بل
باستحالة ترجمه للاستطلاع الراي الذي
اجراه المركز الفلسطيني للدراسات السياسيه
والمسيحيه واعطى حركه حماس الرقم الاول في
انتخابات رئاسه اذا جرت رئاسه اسماعيل
هانيه هو الرئيس واذا جرت انتخابات مجلس
تشريعي مجلس تشريعي فحركت حماس هي الكتله
البرلمانيه الاكبر هذا ثانيا وثالثا هو
ترجمه لما هو على الارض لا توجد مقاومه
ممكن ان تبني كل هذه المقدرات و تحتمل و
وتنفق كل هذه الاموال في ظل حاضنه شعبيه
كانت تعاني من حصار وتقبل ذلك اي هناك
حاضنه شعبيه للمقاومه في قطاع غزه قبلت
بوجود هذه المقاومه كرافع لمشروع التحرر
الوطني وامتدت هذه الحاضنه لتصل باقي
مناطق ال الضفه الغربيه وحتى الشتات
والداخل الفلسطيني المحتل في الوسط العربي
وبذلك باتت حركه حماس ايقونه لحاله
المقاومه في فلسطين بشكل عام وايضا لم
تقتصر حماس يعني ارادوا قتلها في غزه
فتمدد لهم فاصبح ينادى بها في لندن وفي
باريس وفي نيويورك وواشنطن وفي كل العواصم
يهتف باسمها وتوضع صوره ابو عبيده كرمزيه
عن الحاله المقاومه في فلسطين بل حتى نجحت
حماس في وضع القضيه الفلسطينيه ضمن اطار
البرو ضمن اطار حرب الروايه والسرد في
اطار
رفعه للقضيه الفلسطينيه والتاكيد على الحق
الفلسطيني لذلك هذه الحرب على المستوى اد
وطبق هذا الواقع الي تتحدث عنه هل سيغير
من التعاطي الدولي مع حركه حماس باتجاه
التساهل ام
التجديد في تقديري اذا وصل المجتمع الدولي
لقناعه با استحاله انهاء حماس وانهاء
المقاومه الفلسطينيه سيكون السيناريو
الثاني هو الاكثر ترجيحا وال يمثل في
احتواء حماس وفي التقارب معها والتعاطي
معها كجزء من الحل وليست المشكله هذا الذي
ربما بدنا نستمع اليه حتى في داخل دوله
الاحتلال هناك اطراف تتحدث بضروره فتح
قنوات اتصال مباشره وان يتم التعاطي مع
حركه حماس وانها هي القوه الاكثر تاثيرا
واكثر فعلا في الحاله الفلسطينيه هذا
بالتاكيد نتاج ماذا نتاج ليس حبا من الشعب
العربي والاسلامي والع
والفلسطيني بحركه حماس وكان عيونها زرقاء
بالتاكيد لا هذا هو نتاج السلوك
الاسرائيلي في انسداد الافق السياسي مع
الرئيس محمود عباس وفي ظل الجرائم
الاسرائيليه وميل المجتمع الاسرائيلي الى
اليمينيه والتطرف كل ذلك سيصنع البديل
وذلك كلما استمر الحرب على غزه في هذا ضمن
هذا المنطق منطق الاباده الجماعيه والعقاب
الجماعي في تقديري ان شعبيه حماس وتجذر
حماس وشعب عبيه المقاومه وفكره المقاومه
حتى لو قتلوا السنوار واعتقلوا الضيف
وقتلوا ابو عبيده ستبقى هذه الفكره راسخه
لا يمكن ان تموت لذلك اقصر الطرق وهذه
رساله عبر الجزيره للولايات المتحده
والمجتمع الغربي اقصر الطرق هو المقاربه
السياسيه اذا قبلت حماس بحل الدولتين وقبل
العالم وقبلت منظمه التحرير بحل الدولتين
فعلى الجميع ان ياتي لدفع اسرائيل لحل
الدولتين ضمن قرار مجلس امن يوقف اطلاق
النار ويبحث عن صفقه شامله منها صفقه
تبادل اسرى ومنها انهاء الصراع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي وبعد ذلك سترى سلاح حماس وسلاح
الجهاد ضمن جيش فلسطيني منظم وضمن يعني
منطق سياسي تحكم القانون الدولي وضمن منطق
نهضوي حضاري وليس ضمن منطق ما يجري لن
تستطيع اسرائيل انهاء فكره المقاومه بالبت
في ظل يعني وجود احتلال شكرا لك سيد حسام
الدجني الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من غزه و